he's a brent mussberger the lead
play-by-play voice for the SEC network
signing a contract extension with the
mothership Brent how are you this
morning I'm fine dan how are you I'm
friend I'm great what is the game plan
for Brent Musburger today I am just
coming back from tending to my son's two
Labradors he's on a on a brief holiday
and I've got a couple of the little dogs
in the car we get the irrigation started
out here in Montana and then I'll hit up
and and danna I'll hit the little white
ball a couple of times a day and play a
little golf and enjoy the beautiful
Montana weather you ought to bring the
show out here you ought to do it from
Yellowstone and glacier during the
summer we'd love to have you out here do
you have a broadcast set up at your
house print yes yes we have we have a
studio and my son could get you all set
up in there and uh you bring the boys
out then we'll have a will have a
hootenanny wow I like that I like that
congratulations on the new contract
there yes exited at least somebody
stayed right but you talked about this
with Joe Paterno and you said he'll
coach till he dies are you going to
broadcast until you die I certainly hope
so uh I would be a terrible retiree I
keep I Creek shredding those letters
from the AARP because I'm just not ready
but you have the enthusiasm and I think
enthusiasm is the first thing to leave
us and it's not just in this business
but really in other jobs you still have
it I marvel I even said this to Mike
Tirico a couple years ago I said Brent
could be in Iowa on a Tuesday night for
Iowa Penn State basketball and have the
same kind of enthusiasm you'd have if
it's you know a bigger event and I
marvel at that I think that that's a
great character trait that you have and
you continue to maintain
you know dad I'm blessed very lucky I've
been around athletics really all my life
as I told you before would love to have
been a participant but i but i was not
that good at any particular game but i
loved it all I love people to compete
and i love the folks that i'm around you
know now working with jessi palmer and
it's a delight he does some work on good
morning america as you know and he
started well traveled and well-educated
I covered him as a player actually but
he was a quarterback job with the Gators
and he played for Steve Spurrier
downside I really don't lose my
enthusiasm simply because I enjoy the
people that's I think that's very
important of my best friends are evolved
deeply and in sport I love the
broadcasting part of it i wanna you know
like you just you were talking about the
Golden State Warriors and last night my
wife and I enjoyed watching Game one of
the finals when when I got spare time
and I'm not doing anything I tune on the
television and watch you watch ballgames
I mean one of my great delights this
year is hoping that the Cubs get over
there they're bad century plus and and
finally get into the World Series and
they're off to a great start so as you
can tell I mean if I'm not working my
passions athletics I love it in when I
get home from the office of road I look
forward to you fellows on on Sunday
night and now you're going to add
thursday night to the redwoods war and
and it's great i don't think that
anything comes across on television
quite like a sporting event it's just
great to watch to watch the fellows
compete at the highest level run down
some of your favorite broadcasting
moments just just to let people know
you've done this a long long time and
and you started you know when the
pregame show on CBS but as far as games
that you've been involved in can you
have you know dan there's uh there are
so many a target the got in fact that i
guess the moment i remember are the
aftermath such as the Doug
looting game down in down in Miami Lee
of the editing of the tape that you
never see when Miami late in that fourth
quarter marching down for a touchdown
and a timeout is called we had a plaid
Mike I was the best in the business and
he was right over with Jimmie Johnson
when Bernie Kosar came over and Jimmy
said to Bernie what do you want to do
and without hesitating Bernie said run
the bleep and ball right to bleep a nap
and I mean it was you know an era
Parseghian and pat haden book got very
very quiet on me so I just had to say
well folks I guess we know what he wants
to do and he did he ran mel bratton into
the end zone smashmouth football it
looked like they were going to win the
game it and when you go back and you
watch the replay because absolutely game
is replayed all the time in the fall you
do not see that that has been taken out
is on the cutting room floor some some
places it always amuses me things like
that i did not know who caught the ball
but fortunately I had a boston college
graduate in the truck he was an
executive by the name of Kevin O'Malley
and he pulled on the keys back and said
it's Gerard Saillant phailin plant and
so then on the replay the first replay I
was able to mention Valens name and it
turned out that Doug Flutie didn't know
who caught the ball yes Lyman all the
way up the tunnel who caught the ball
and a the center looked at him and said
your roommate caught it and that's how
he realized that it was failing so it's
that I always think it's the little
things that go on around the broadcast I
mean everybody members a game and sees
them but but we have things behind the
scenes that and I'm sure you're the same
way with with some of your broadcast
through the years we how is the game
changed in how we're supposed to
broadcast it I mean it's social media
changed anything or it do is your
approach have to be different well I
think that social media has changed it
dramatic I don't think it changes it
that much for me except that I realize
that there's a word
trending that goes on out there with
certain things and I was made aware
during the one championship game that a
lovely lady by the name of Katherine
Webb was trending I can't imagine why
[ __ ] hater famous Brent all she was
doing fine on holiday yeah she's now
mother and happily married to AJ and I
hope they live happily ever after I I
was delighted to see AJ play so well in
place of injured Andy Dalton for a while
we wish Dalton the best but it looked to
me actually like a.j might have a future
but but back to your question I don't
think it changes my job that much but I
realize that people come in and out of
broadcast because of social media and
they talk to each other and they say
there's a good game but there's a bad
game and so I guess if there's anything
we have to continually update the public
as to what's happening you've got a new
audience coming in especially if a game
it's uh is really developing into
something you've got to tell that
audience how how the game got to the
point where we're a fresh audience is
coming into our I would guess that the
attention span Danny's is down I think
only the most passionate hardcore fans
probably watched from the first snap to
the last they duck in and out so those
little things um technically will I
thought it would we're like the athletes
I mean the technology that's been
developed throughout my lifetime is uh
is unbelievable in it and of course the
football experience in particular the
sport was made for for television
instant replay and all the different
angles and cameras that we can bring
back through the years I mean it's it's
a marvel of what we of what were able to
put out out of the air for the fan now I
can see why certain folks have been fans
for a long long time of gone to the
stadiums actually better stay home and
and that's uh that's I think the tribute
to the technology people I doubt that
the broadcasting itself has changed all
that much more a little more informed
we're probably a little more apt to to
mention negative stories for example
whoever draws the baylor assignments
issue in football they will refer to the
the sexual troubles and the reason why
the coach was fired etc and back in the
day when I when I first started some of
those negative stories were not not
mentioned on in vodcast and I think I
think we've all grown past that so I
think those things those things have
changed a lot through the years I I
haven't an idea I presented this to Al
Michaels it's steak night in America
starring Al Michaels so it's just it's a
steakhouse tour without Michaels because
he the only eat steak now we were
thinking about this yesterday when we
knew we were going to have you on we
would do a pub crawl with you brent
mussberger so it's a must burger tour of
uh you know bars taverns looking for the
best hamburger we'll shoot it for TV are
you in I am all in I like it I like it
you just tell me where the first month
I'll be there will you wear the cowboy
hat I will definitely wear the cowboy
hat I'll put on a new pair of boots boys
I like that I like that final question
it's a serious one more handsome Jesse
Palmer Kirk Herbstreit hahaha well
because he's still a bachelor I'm
leading to Jesse okay okay all right I
think that's the politically correct
answer it's close but you give Jesse
even on there I do I I give I give Jesse
to not because I have been with both of
them around uh you know groups of the
other side here and I can see who
generates the most attention yeah and
I'll leave it at that oh okay all right
well done hey congrats always great to
talk to you Brent and good luck playing
golf today thank you thanks dad will
talk to your daughter Rose all right
Brent Musburger ESPN SEC network
77 he's great the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience